go big show may just be the most bonkers
thing i've ever seen
i know right me too me too it is
wild but i think that that to me is one
of the things that attracted me
you know to doing it is how unique how
different
and how absolutely bonkers it is how how
was it pitched to you
um you know really how it was pitched
was was
as as in just that way that it was
something unique and different you know
we have so many
uh talent competition shows that are
performing arts based
um singing or dancing this is everything
except that
and that was how it pitched to me like
everything except that extreme and on
steroids you know like
extreme animal handling extreme motor
sports extreme
body manipulation extreme trick shots
like you know all of it to the extreme
so is that what drew you to this or was
the
aspect of just being on a show like this
or was it the actual
specifics of the show no i loved the
specifics of the show that it was so
different you know i've done some
some work before on some competition
shows that were performing arts based
um and and while i definitely enjoy that
and find value in that for me this to be
so
different i i just i got such a kick out
of it you know and i'm a fan
as well of live entertainment right so
so to get to
to sit on the front row for all of this
madness and sometimes also be invited to
participate i was
all in that's it so much of the
the the show you spend like this right
funny there is that like a lot of people
spend the show like that
and the guys snoop and cody
were really the ones like hiding behind
the seat while rosario and i the women
were like leaning in like
this is fascinating what even is this
you know
so for me the reactions as well
to the performances were as as
entertaining as the performances
themselves
this may also be one of the most
entertaining
panel of judges on any sort of
talent-based show that i've come across
what's the dynamic like between the four
of you
you know how i have described it and you
hit the nail on the head in terms of
just the diversity
you know also of of the cast of judges
the whole panel
it's like if you remember the movie the
breakfast club yep
um where it's like this totally diverse
group of kids but you would
absolutely go to saturday detention and
have a ball with them
that is this panel of judges like
everybody is so different but we
all had such a fun time and also too
everybody's kind and respectful you know
this isn't the kind of show
where you have somebody who's you know
cast is quote unquote the mean one you
know everybody
is is super encouraging and the messages
are all positive
um over the last little while whether it
be boxing or when people get them to do
hockey stuff snoop's commentary
is always so entertaining hi
what did you learn about snoop that
maybe you didn't know going into this
you know i mean i think that in just
being able i had never spent time with
him i had
met him once before years ago um i think
like
backstage at a cmt awards or something
like
there's a picture somewhere of of of us
with him and a cowboy hat like
this was way before old town road you
know what i'm saying he was country when
country wasn't cool you know
so to speak um so i had met him but i
never spent any time with him he is a
major world superstar you know i mean
like if you look on instagram he's got
like
50 million okay yeah
he's a superstar so to to get to spend
some time and get to know him
as as a person you know and and watch i
think that's part of the joy of this
show as well
to get to to see him in that capacity
he is is not only super talented but but
he
is very kind and warm and and
compassionate and and celebratory you
know he is a lovely lovely person
was there one talent or one sort of a
contestant i guess
um that left a big impression on you
whether it was because you were
terrified for them or you had never seen
it before
what was the sort of one takeaway where
you were like i can't still cannot
believe
i saw that yeah there were a few of
those moments you know that there will
and not to spoil or alert you know ruin
it for
for people who haven't seen some of the
show yet but i i think you know
there are definitely acts who overcome
um extreme physical challenges to do
what it is that they do
uh either because of how they were born
or through accidents that happened to
them and yet
they have come up with these beautiful
fantastic
and amazing ways to to showcase and
celebrate
their talents um and then there were
some acts that were
really just shocking and amazing in
in the extremes some people broke not
only their own records but broke world
records during this show
with some of the things that they were
doing you know there's one in particular
who
i would call it uh somewhere between
body manipulation
sideshow and martial arts because
there was a ton of really like spiritual
connectivity
for this act in particular there's some
sword swallowing among other things but
um and again i don't want to give it
away for people
for me i think those kinds of acts were
the most impactful
what about the guy who can stick cans
and bottles to his face
wild i was not expecting
that at all you know he he called
himself the human mutant
and we were all trying to guess like
they gave us all an opportunity
on the on the judges panel to guess like
what it wasn't and some people did guess
i think rosario said like are you
magnetic you know like magneto or
whatever and by the time it got to me
everybody had guessed like something
that
it could be probable and i was like i
don't know like are you a super
chugger you know like what are you gonna
do with these cans dude i don't know
um and yeah that was that was pretty
wild something about the oxygenation
of his blood i i don't know
i have no idea but it was awesome uh
what kind of can you give us an update
on music what's happening
in the in the in your music world um
well like all of us in the live
entertainment industry
you know so many projects have been
were shelved in 2020 that i was hoping
to be able to release and so i hope i'll
be able to get there
and and you know get out there and
release them this year i have a couple
of solo projects
um a theater album of broadway tunes
being one of them another one being uh
spanish english collaboration
um album and then obviously sugarland
had already announced new music and and
had a tour that we had to cancel so
i'm i'm hoping you know and this is in
addition to
you know movies and and and things that
i'm i'm
starring in and writing and working on
and producing and so
i i just hope we can you know all get
out there
sooner rather than later and do what we
love you know
now are you going to be back in season
two of the righteous gemstones
that is the plan that is speaking of
yeah waiting that that's uh
hoping to be able to to get on set and
and
get that production up and rolling in a
safe way soon because
i had such a blast being a part of that
show and what a fantastic character and
danny mcbride is so super talented
walton goggins
you know the whole the whole cast is
really amazing
uh what i wonder what your reaction is
between danny mcbride and
and walton because they've done multiple
shows together before
and the words that come out of their
mouth and the way that they string
things together
is like so it's almost artistic how
shocking it is uh-huh no they they
definitely
have a talent and they have such a such
a rapport
between the two of them you know you can
tell that over the productions and the
years and the shows that they've done
together
they have a trust for each other between
what danny writes and and then what
walton
ends up interpreting um and i had such a
blast
with walton i learned more in my scene
work with him
than any sort of workshop or anything
that i have ever taken in in my career
from acting just because
he's he's such an extreme talent
yeah um before i let you go the
we've been dealing with now the pandemic
for almost a year
um but coming up the thing that we
didn't have
last year that we will have this year is
valentine's day during a pandemic do you
have you thought about that yet i know
it's kind of creeping up on us do you
have valentine's day plans
you know i haven't even thought about it
again it's just so crazy for us because
our world
has gotten so small so it's not like you
say like well let's make plans to go out
to dinner because
no that doesn't feel safe and
responsible um so
i guess yeah i don't know i don't know
what that will end up being for people i
i haven't considered it maybe i should
start
and how are you with sort of planning
for this new kind of world i mean as
somebody who is
used to big crowds and big stages and
big productions
uh have you adapted do you think that
you're you're doing okay you know i just
had this conversation
literally yesterday in terms of
adaptation and and to watch
the rhythms that this year
has taken from when we were all shocked
of like in lockdown for the first three
months of you know what's gonna happen
to okay maybe like acceptance
trying to figure something out to okay
this has rocked on long enough
my life has been different and out of my
control for so long
so many people are suffering so many
people don't have jobs
so many people don't know when their
next paycheck is coming everyone is
depressed
i've reached for you know um self
medicating
wine way way too much so i've i've
already
been made the pivot here since christmas
to
to change that and to stop doing that
try to get outside and move my body more
and be more healthy
um but everything is so reactive you
know
what we just we just wait to see what
happens next and how we are going to
adapt to it so
in some ways i feel like i've done okay
i mean i've done
i've done okay that i haven't gotten it
so i'm not sure
you know i'm doing doing okay there um
but
otherwise you know emotionally i there
are times there are good days and there
are bad days with it